nearly a year into the kofit 19 pandemic
local nonprofits like project 150
are continuing to see an increased need
for food assistance
reporter kate houston joins us live in
the newsroom tonight and kate project
150 is now extending its schedule
to help even more families yes sasha
project 150 says
lately they've helped many families that
are using their resources
for the first time in order to reach as
many people as possible
the nonprofit will now offer its food
distribution program
on saturdays this assistance is
available to high school students
and their families it's a contactless
curbside pickup
outside of the project 150 offices on
rancho drive
students will need to make sure they
have their school id number with them
once verified families will receive bags
of non-perishable food
drinks and hygiene products all for free
one high school senior tells me the
program has helped provide some
stability for his family
during a difficult time my family has um
struggled with some you know basic
resources
and but fortunately we have you know
things like one project 150 and we can
actually you know keep going forward
and sometimes it's really hard to choose
between paying the bills and putting
food on the table so if we can bridge
that gap and
put the food on the table that's what
we'll continue to do all year long
project 150 says the distribution day on
saturday is
great for families that work during the
week or students who are in school
food will be given out every saturday in
february from 9 a.m
to 1 p.m project 150 is also taking
volunteers on a limited basis
monday through saturday to continue to
provide help for families
the nonprofit is also collecting
donations of non-perishable unopened
and unexpired food items back to you
sasha